hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome back to my OpenGL series so
today's going to be a pretty cool and
fun episode I think we're gonna be
integrating something called I am GUI I
am G Y M GUI people say it differently I
say I am GUI but basically what I am
doing is is a GUI library kind of thing
that we can use in OpenGL and DirectX
and any kind of rendering API it's
pretty much IP I independent it's a way
for us to just draw UI on the screen and
by you I mean things like buttons text
fields color Pickers just information
windows stuff like that it's really
really useful for debugging purposes and
it's even useful if you want to make
some kind of application quickly in kind
of a real-time rendering setting so like
with graphics and so maybe like if we
were making a game engine and we want to
get a level editor up and running
without having to actually make a
Windows application using QT or WPF or
anything like that you can even just
make it using IM GUI really quickly and
it would just run like a game run like a
real-time application which is really
cool so link time GUI will be in this in
the description below the idea for
today's episode is just to basically
integrate it into our existing opengl
code base the reason we're doing this is
because going forward it's gonna be
really really useful for us to have a UI
kind of that we can just spin up really
quickly for kind of debugging purposes
so for a it's gonna be really easy for
me to just bring up values on the screen
that we can see and edit and then see
that how that effects our actual
graphics but also for kind of debugging
we want graphs if we want framerate if
we want kind of buttons that we can
click the trigger certain things it's
really easy to kind of do all that with
with a library like I'm GUI and the same
cells having to write our own UI library
which to be honest can take like really
long time so anyway without further ado
let's just go in and take a look at what
we've got so if we can just run our code
to see where we were at last time you
can see we had this channel logo and we
had a Model View projection matrix that
we made consisting of a projection
matrix of view matrix and model matrix
as always all this code is available on
github if you're a patron so check out
Petra non compos - the Cherno if you're
not and sign up to get all this code
individually per episode that's what
we're gonna be starting from the kind of
Model View projection episode all that
car is gonna be the basis for this
entire episode okay
the first thing we're going to do is get
I'm dewy so if you check out the link in
the description or just Google I'm going
I'm sure you'll find it if we go to the
releases page here I'm just going to
download the source code for version 1.6
it was released twelve days ago at the
time making this video so I'm just gonna
get the zip archive of all the source
code for this version of I'm going once
I've got that if I open that you'll see
we have I'm going 1.6 now there are a
few things here that we care about we
don't care about all this like we never
really need all the examples you can see
there's everything here from Apple to
DirectX a bunch of DirectX versions
old-school kind of OpenGL more modern
OpenGL in Vulcan and STL and there's a
lot of different things we don't care
about a lot of these what we do care
about is oh the OpenGL 3 example because
that one happens to be using gel FW
which is what we're using and that's
gonna just make it really really easy
for us integrated quickly and the other
thing we care about is of course the
actual I'm doing so from I'm going what
we actually need is all this stuff
basically so if I copy all of these kind
of specifically and header files that we
have here like that so that's oldham if
I copy them I'm going to go ahead and
open my vendor folder and then from here
I'm just gonna make a folder called hime
GUI and then just paste in all my code
into there so the other thing that I
wanted was that J love W example so if I
go back to to this zip file and into
examples and where is Jill does OpenGL 3
I'm just gonna grab these three now we
don't really need main I'll copy it out
anyway
we didn't want it or anything but it is
a good kind of example that we can just
use so if I go back here I'll paste all
this stuff in main again we're going to
delete and we probably just want
including our project but it's still
useful to have there for reference okay
cool
so that's all we need fine get it's
really really easy to set up so go back
to Venda I'm just gonna hit this refresh
button up here at the top and I'm going
to basically include everything from
here I'm just gonna exclude that one
maybe I'll see BB file because we do not
want that so exclude from project but
again we'll keep it around here for
reference okay so to set this up if we
take a look at this gfw example here one
thing that it does is it actually uses
GL 3w instead of glue we're just gonna
change that so we'll get rid of this
comment and we'll change this to be
GW and guess all changes comment here as
well that's pretty much it if I hit ctrl
f7 this should just compile you can see
it does so let's try compiling the whole
project now that we've included all
these I'm GUI files perfectly everything
works fine and as you can see there we
go
no errors let me just drag this out but
wind over here now Aris everything is
fine beautiful so now we just need to
integrate it into our application so to
do that a really easy way to do that is
just to take a look at this main dos apk
file that we excluded because that
basically has an example so really all
we need to do here is we need to create
the context farm GUI we need to call
this jail of w3 in it that function is
found inside this chill kill jail Toby
free example that they have here and you
can see it registers all these kind of
key bindings it takes care of that for
for us you can see that all we have to
do is pass in the window pointer into an
it and it will just set up all the input
bindings so it's really really cool
style colors dark sure why not and then
it's got some examples on actually use
it just as for our run loop we just need
to start a new frame and at the end we
just need to basically end the frame
using angular render and then rendered
raw data just for gow3 and that's pretty
much it
football to draw done so that it
actually renders it using OpenGL and at
the end we can do shutdown and that's
pretty much it so if I just dock this
side-by-side let's go ahead and start
copying some of this code I'm gonna zoom
out a little bit hopefully you guys can
still see everything this will just be
for a bit while I copy this stuff but
basically let's grab that create context
that we have here I'm put it at the top
so right before we do our loop here
maybe after we create the lander I'll
say Oh Paul I'm going create context now
we need to include this because it's in
our vendor folder we should just be able
to do include I am GUI slash I'm GUI H
and we'll also have to include that jail
so we did three example sorry this one
here great ok so we create the context
we're then going to initialize this so
we'll just pass that in you can see I
mean it's even called this time simple
winter in both examples we really
literally don't have to change anything
we'll go ahead and set up that style and
set it to dark and that's it for the
initialization let's go ahead and start
a new frame now this doesn't have to be
if this is has something to do with
setting a new frame in terms of like a
new gel W frame it's just fine GUI so we
can just put this here
doesn't matter I'll put it off to the
renderer clear you could put it anywhere
just make sure you put it like in
between your your I'm good code so
before you start any I'm giving code for
this frame you want to have the new
frame function call and then at the end
there's I'm going render and then that
kind of draw our render draw down a
thing so I'll do that right with what we
swap the buffers and then finally we
have a shutdown so there's a few lines
for that and that's right before gel
Toby terminate so we'll put it right
there that is yet okay so now let's try
and render a window this main example
also has that which is beautiful you can
see if there's a bit of a window over
here let's copy that I'll put it after I
might put it after we render everything
so maybe right over here and then there
are a few variables at the top here that
we want to also copy let's just put that
here and let's close man I'll put the
text size back up let's hit f5 and see
what we get okay so check the how that
was really easy and you can see now what
we have is there's a window that we can
kind of move around and everything's
everything's pretty beautiful there so
we can change the color I can even click
over here and adjust the color of
everything now you'll notice that it is
a bit offset from my mouse pointer and
that's actually this laptop for some
reason windows dpi scaling or something
I don't know exactly what's going on but
the mouse pointer is just offset for a
lot of applications if I even open
something like mischief up which is a
paint roaring app you can see that it
draws way offset from my cursor when I'm
at the top of the screen and then if I
kind of go down it kind of matches I
don't know how well you guys can see
that but if anyone knows what on earth
is going on here it's been really
frustrating it's just this laptop it's
not the only kind of high resolution 4k
whatever
I've got Eva so I'm not sure why but
it's just this one it seems to be
completely wrong so don't worry about if
you're like you I'm do we should be
completely fine but you can see that
yeah if you even got like color pickers
and this is just an example of kind of
what you have here and then all of these
settings in like yeah we can drag this
around we can resize this window hope we
like I just need to find my mouse
pointer this is so annoying that ago so
yeah that's why I'm GUI there's a great
example of how it works
now let's actually do something useful
with it in our code so I'll get rid of
all these all this kind of example stuff
that we have here in this whole example
window we don't need one thing I will
keep is this I guess is a lot of large
because that'll be useful I don't get
rid of everything and I guess we'll keep
this frame right thing because it's kind
of useful okay
so now one thing I want to do here is
we've just talked about model matrices
and how we can use them to translate our
actual geometry let's go ahead and make
this kind of model matrix something that
we can actually edit live so to do that
I'm gonna copy basically these two lines
and paste them over here where we
actually do our uniform submission so we
need the model matrix and we need the
MVP and then what I'll do with that is
I'll just get rid of the model matrix
from here and the MVP from here I'll cut
this MVP line this actual uniform
setting and I will put it over here with
the other uniforms so now we're
basically just recalculating the model
matrix and the MVP every frame which is
totally fine so now let's add something
time to it that lets us actually kind of
modify this so right now it's just the
GLM back three and that's something that
we're passing into this translate
ceiling function I'll cut that and I'll
put up with that outside of our run loop
so maybe over here and I'll call this
translation will still start it at 200
200 and zero now if I go back here I'll
paste in translation and then into I am
gooey I'll use something called a slide
foot three probably just use a flight to
it because we just care abouts and why
but we'll use this five foot three and
I'll pass in the memory address of
translation X now I'm not really sure
this takes a you can see this takes a
flirt array I'm not really sure how to
get that out of GLM though if we look at
that if we look at what about three is
that's for lower P ok hi P Dec 3 it's
just a type def on Feb 3 you can see
that the thing that's using is just a
union of T X Y Zed T is fluid so we have
XY said it's pretty much how you expect
a vector to be laid out the reason it's
a union of this of course just so that
we can basically address it by the XYZ
or RGB or STP whatever kind of variable
names we want to use and they of course
mean the same thing but I can't really
see anything I was looking through this
a bit earlier that returns an actual
array like a pointer to everything you
can see this is for density so I'm not
exactly sure maybe there is a way but
right now I'm just gonna pass in the
memory address of the first variable
which is X or R whatever you want to
here so I'll use X of course and that's
just gonna give it the memory address of
X and then of course the next one in
memories nobody wins that so everything
will work as expected because the memory
layout is the same as a flood array ok
so anyway but the bouncer will set or
maybe zero and nine 6960 because we have
our projection matrix I believe set to
be up to 960 and that's really all we
have to do I mean of course where this
is this is basically setting up a
three-component slider that we can use
to modify this translation vector which
is being passed into model and being
used for our MVP matrix which we passed
into our shader so everything is kind of
linking up if we hit up if we hit f5 to
run our code here you can see what we
get is this and if I move this window
out to the side a little bit what I can
do is change the this value here this is
the X position this is the Y position
and you can see that it moves everything
right and if I put everything to 0-0 you
can see it's not really quite the bottom
here and that would be because I think
in our vertex buffer yeah you can see we
don't actually hit the bottom anywhere
we're kind of at 100 by 200 so that is
why that's not in the very kind of
bottom left anyway yeah that's a great
example of why I'm going is really
useful I just let's look quickly bring
up stuff like this that we can control
well while our actual code is running so
to keep recompiling and it's really
gonna help me to show some of these
things that we cover in this series in a
bit more detail now unfortunately I hate
this mouse offset thing maybe I can
actually think about solving that for
next time
but I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did you can hit the like button
you can also help support the series by
going patreon a cupful / the chair as
always like every the code for every
video goes up on github and if you're a
patron you can access that so be sure to
take a look at this code if you want to
make sure you didn't make any errors or
anything like that it was really really
simple to integrate I'm gooey I mean you
saw how easy it was really no big deal
if I was kind of running my own engine I
probably may have rewritten they're kind
of shell if Delta you think to also
include all the API it's like DirectX or
whatever I supported so this series is
obviously just about OpenGL I just
thought I'd throw I'm gooey in because
it's gonna help me explain a lot of
OpenGL concepts a lot easier because I
can kind of manipulate things live
but anyway next time what are we gonna
move on to next time that is so much to
cover you'll have to just wait until
next time you see what ends up happening
I'll see you then good bye
[Music]